good afternoon everybody you're very
welcome here I'm Steph Newell
um from The English Department here at
Yale it's my great greatest pleasure to
introduce our distinguished speaker this
evening the Nobel Laureate Professor
Abdul razak gerna
um let me start with some thanks to our
sponsors and organizers
um Professor Garner's visit to Yale has
been made possible by generous funding
from the Council on African studies at
the Yale MacMillan Center as well as the
Trumbull endowed lecture fund the
Whitney Humanities Center the office of
the dean of humanities and The English
Department
meanwhile over several months and with
meticulous attention to detail Kristen
Siebert and marabad Kabul of the African
of the Council on African studies and
the Yale MacMillan Center have organized
everything for Professor Garner's visit
from transportation to venues to food to
drink to much much more so Kristin and
marwa wherever you are there they are at
the back please let's say thank you to
them for all of our congratulations
so our preparations have been supported
all along the way by the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center Professor
Alice Kaplan and the associate director
Diane Barrett Brown and thanks also go
to the chair of the English Department
Mark Robinson the chair of the Council
on African studies professor katatana
heka and the dean of humanities
Professor Katie Lofton and they've all
been very supportive and we're also
grateful to Jen castellon and Michael
Miranda at the binecke library and you
of all very warmly invited after this
lecture to the beineke library for a
reception and a musical treat
um we're also very grateful to the
students helpers who are here to help
out this afternoon so now as you may
have gathered as you came in um Your
Presence at this venue is an indication
of your consent to the recording of that
we're making of Professor Gunner's
lecture so we'll have time for a short q
a after this but by putting your hands
up and receiving the microphone you're
also implicitly uh uh agree and
consenting to being recorded
um we've also got a bookstore outside
which you may have seen on your way in
you're very welcome to buy copies of
books and Professor Garner has very
um kindly agreed to sign books after the
lecture for a very short period of time
um so welcome welcome to you and now
when Abdul razak gerna was named winner
of the Nobel Prize for literature in
2021. his Publishers were caught off
guard by the overnight up search in
demand for his novels and for a brief
period as Supply caught up with demand
printed copies of his Works vanished
from the shelves bookshops struggled to
restock and the New York Times
complained in a headline he won the
Nobel why are his books so hard to find
meanwhile the reaction of literary
Scholars to Professor kerners Nobel
Prize was a noisy of course
as the Sudanese British author Leila Abu
Laila put it she says now our well-kept
secret is out in the open
for more than three decades Professor
Garner has been an influential figure
among post-colonial literary Scholars
he's the author of 10 novels numerous
short stories academic books reflective
essays and scholarly articles and as
professor of literature at the
University of Canterbury his work has
helped to shape our field so when
literary Scholars think about the
oceanic histories of East Africa for
example and those old The Old Spice
Roots connecting Zanzibar with India and
the Arab world or when they think about
the experiences of different kinds of
migrants from Africa to the global North
they turn to his fiction
from the outset with the publication of
his first novel memory of departure in
1987. Professor gerna has focused on
ordinary people caught up in momentous
events in East Africa so they're often
set in Zanzibar where he was born but
also in the neighboring countries of
Tanzania and Kenya his novels feature
characters whose lives are impacted by
War colonialism decolonization but often
who have little control over the events
that shape their worlds
what Horizons open and close healths in
the lives of ordinary Africans when they
coincide with these seismic political
Transformations on the continent that
are beyond their control
how do they navigate through violent
events like European colonialism world
wars fascism displacement revolutionary
postcolonial conflict
in his Nobel Prize lecture Professor
gerner describes his creative writing as
retrieving stories and again and again
you can see this process of retrieval in
his fiction whether it's an old man on
his deathbed with the secret to disclose
to his family as in the last gift or a
young man who escapes domestic slavery
into another form of servitude in the
east African German Army in First World
War as that's in his most recent novel
afterlives his work focuses on the
figures whose experiences and feelings
are either absent from the written
archives or so thoroughly overwritten by
Colonial racial categories that their
subjective experiences can't be
recomposed from the historical record
as the narrator puts it in afterlives
East Africa has simply been a sideshow
to the great tragedies in Europe
and Professor Garner's fiction you do
not find a comfortable retrieval of
stories into visibility many of his
characters experience false memories or
sometimes their lives take on substance
and become part of their family history
or new memories displace old ones or
stories become riddled with doubts
but complicated as the stories and
memories of his characters are as their
lives unfold in each novel we see
Tangled accounts giving way to
confessions confusion and evasion giving
way to clarification time and again in
his novels
histories are corrected memories are set
right
while you find many different kinds of
narrator in Professor gerner's novels
but you also find many different scenes
of listening and examples of listeners
as stories are told and retold the way
people in their stories are received is
vital to his work a failure to listen is
shown to be another form of violence
you cannot imagine what that time was
like says the mother of the narrator of
gravel heart as she tries yet again to
describe the trauma of the January 1964
revolution in Zanzibar you cannot
imagine the terror of it the arrests the
deaths the humiliations people were
driving each other mad with rumors of
new outrages new decrees with news of
further Sorrows but yes you can imagine
you must try nothing stands between us
and atrocities but words so there is no
choice but to try and imagine
if you stop trying to tell your story
she continues after a while it becomes
as if these things did not really happen
did not really happen like that as if
you're exaggerating if you speak of them
so if you so you stop speaking and they
recede even further away they become
even more unreal become even less
possible to imagine
and you tell yourself it's time to move
on let them go it's not worth the bother
of remembering
but they do not let you go
like the listeners inside his stories
after us at gerner calls on us as
readers as listeners to imagine and in
so doing to inhabit and remember the
lives of his characters tonight's
lecture is called writing memory please
welcome Professor Abdel Rosa Ghana
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you Steph
thank you that was a a wonderful
introduction
and thank you all for being here
I'm very happy to be here and to answer
the question that I'm sure you
birding to get an answer to Is yes it's
the first time I'm coming to Yale
well it seems to be wherever you go
people say is this the first time you're
here so you know I like to get this out
of the way as soon as possible so yes it
is yes it is it's good to be here
um
it's been relatively nice
a lot nicer than where we've come from
in the UK
anyways really Steph thank you very much
for that introduction that appreciation
um
I've already met some of you uh
I met some of you yesterday some of the
students yesterday and I know and have
heard already from you I'm so glad to
see you again
okay so uh it's always uh interesting
when you're invited to give a lecture
say a year before the lecture is due to
be given and so we said all right what
are you going to talk about
uh and you know nothing's further away
from your thoughts than this event is
going to happen a year hence
but I knew that this uh this idea this
topic of memory this that it's something
that I think about
a lot and talk about and write about so
I thought this would be something
that it might be interesting to put some
ideas together and see what comes out
so for a writer
or at least for a writer of a certain
kind
a writer like I mean in that respect not
the person but because the kind of
writing I do so for a writer
of that kind the kind I'm familiar with
memory is a vital resource
I'm not referring to the ability to
remember when I say memory to remember
certain facts or details
but I'm referring to the swamp of
memories that Linger on long after the
moment has passed
in which at times strike out of Silence
to leave one quivering with sorrow
34 is lucky he was unexpected elation
I think of this idea of memory this idea
of memory is not facts
or not remembered things exactly but
this kind of I call it swap but you know
what I mean this kind of uh indefinable
thing that looks all the time there and
every now and again surfaces and catches
you
I think of this idea of memory as a
writer's Hinterland
in the sense that that painter land in
the sense that large Urban centers
depend on the country around them to
provide the means to sustain them
I use this word to describe memory and
somebody says why do you want to use a
German word no no Hinterland is not a
German word into a level geography or
something like that
uh
but another way of speaking the
hinterland in the sense of it provides
the source material the place where the
writer goes back to for uh to to kind of
check the plausibility of certain
Notions and ideas and that's
it but another way of speaking about
memory is to describe it as experience
we remember what we have experienced
and we do so in a profound sense of that
word experience
so there may be events
experience maybe events which befell us
in person
or Stories We heard about other people
and other places
or news
or histories we read about
all dreams and imaginings
that thrill excuse me that thrilled or
baffled us
I think of experiences all of those
things this is this is what goes on in
our consciousness
both because we live it because we hear
about it because we read about it or in
other ways we imagine it we anticipate
it because of what we already know
it's the writers
self-inflicted burden to make something
engaging productive or even beautiful
out of this
the recall of memory in writing
performs several of these functions that
I've been touching on it engages
the recording of memory and writing
engages by evoking Salient details
it makes the engagement productive
because we believe in it
we find it plausible
or and we hear Echoes of it in our own
knowledge there's that all this lovely
moment when you're reading something and
you kind of without being aware and
you're nodding because you think yes yes
yes yes yes because we're hearing
something that is both persuasive but
also because we recognize something
and if the writer has been blessed with
the ability and insight the product is
even beautiful so you you not only nod
and say that but you think oh gosh
that's good how did he do that
we read for comparably complex ends
there is pleasure
in the engagement itself I would have
thought that's probably the primary uh
part of the experience of reading it
doesn't work if there isn't that
so there is pleasure in the engagement
which is difficult to describe
that which is palpable which is
something we can feel
when we feel it
that pleasure it seems to me is as I
just mentioned primary unless of course
if we're in the midst of a university
literature program
we see our inclinations and ideas
expressed more persuasively than we are
capable of doing ourselves
we're exposed to places and times and
ways of thinking
some of which are familiar and some
completely unfamiliar
in other words in addition to the
pleasure of reading something
beautifully or powerfully expressed
we also receive news
we love
the least of these functions that I've
been trying to summarize this if you
like why do we read
or what do we get out of breeding the
least of these functions
which the recall of memory and writing
performs
is to evoke Nostalgia for a lost time
to speak a lament for a contentment
which is no longer possible
nostalgia in this sense would seem to
refer to a kind of self-deception
an introspective desire to see what is
passed more positively than the present
state
and as Scholars
and students of literature we are often
skeptical of such drops
indeed we are trained to be skeptical
and there are good reasons for this
both in Reading literature
and in living Our Lives
because at worst
sentiment can also be a means of evasion
a refusal to acknowledge responsibility
for what was done in our name
on the other hand
let's not be in a hurry to throw out
this word nostalgia
you can find this out by just checking
on on Google the word nostalgia derives
from the Greek words nostas
which means return in Algos which means
pain
and one of its meanings
is the distress aroused by a yearning
for one's place of origin
it's a yearning that those who have lost
their places of origin have lost their
homes no only too well
in recent times
we have witnessed a strange panic
in Europe about the arrival
of what I described as refugees
you are familiar with that panic in this
country as well
but I'll restrict my remarks to Europe
in order to avoid homogenizing
complicated issues
which is one of the problems of the
representation of people on the move
it has become common to refer to all
arrivals from outside of Europe as
refugees
when perhaps more nuanced terms would
enable us to see the phenomenon of
displacement in migration more clearly
the use of this word
in reference to the population upheavals
of normal of non-european people
is inflected with criminal and malicious
intention
and subsequent social Jeopardy for the
destination country
more often than not it is emptied of the
threat to life
and the desperate distress
that prompted the flight in the first
place
refugees are not a new phenomenon for
Europe or for anywhere else in the world
but for Europe
which has been convulsed in Relentless
Wars
on its own soil for centuries is even
less of an unknown
phenomena
these movements
were not only within Europe
but large ones to North and South
America
the victims of economic and social
distress on the move
even larger numbers of Europeans went or
were sent to what we now call the global
South
these were not refugees
or they were not all refugees
but people empowered at times
involuntarily
by the expansionist ideologies of their
states
to displace them dispossess
non-european people of their rights and
their lands and at times their lives
and to call this process a civilizing
mission
the incredible destruction
of the 20th century Wars
so not only the pulverization of
prosperous and densely populated cities
and territories
but an unprecedented forced transfer of
people
what else is a refugee
but a creature on the move as a result
of such circumstances
when we speak of such a figure we should
remind ourselves
that the European colonization of the
continents was also a deprivation of the
rights and lands of native peoples
some of whom now have no recourse but to
seek the safety and prosperity which
their oppression has produced
how should we begin to think
about the human obligation in this
phenomenon
what are we to do
to me it seems
both a moral and human obligation to
offer hospitality
to people whose lives are at risk
and indeed to avoid criminalizing a
desire for safety and self-fulfillment
I began by speaking about memory as a
vital resource of a certain kind of
writer or for a certain kind of writer
and I'll return to that presently in the
light of the representation and the
self-representation of the displaced
figure
recently in my
tour of the world
the Recently I was asked to speak in the
same way like this like I mentioned at
the beginning uh will you give actually
I wasn't even asked I was told you're
you're giving the inaugural address uh
in about two hours and your topic is
like that it happens honestly
but this time my topic was
writing as a form of resistance
talk about that
my first instinct was to resist
because I thought this was one of those
platform statements or other statements
literature is the meaning of life that
kind of
self-congratulation that's commentators
and practitioners of the writing
business are sometimes prone to
but I had to speak to people to whom
this subject had already been announced
so there was no Escape
so I rephrase the topic for myself
if writing is a form of resistance what
is it resistant to
in the first place I think
resistance to forgetfulness
what oppressions and tragedies befall
people at the hands of powerful forces
and what is known and believed in can no
longer be known and believed in in the
same way
the compulsion is to move on
to get on with it to forget
precisely the passage you quoted
although I didn't know you're about to
do that
it's a compulsion endorsed
by those responsible for such events so
we prefer that we do forget that we do
not remember what led to our present
state
a few years ago a British prime minister
on a visit to Tanzania was exasperated
by a question about colonialism
and he was reported to reply why are you
talking about colonialism
it's over
forget about it and let's move on
it was Gordon Brown
our own governments would also like us
to forget about their atrocities too and
move on
and in many instances citizens have no
choice but to do so in order to preserve
life and decency
the writers do have a choice
they can choose not to allow
what they know
and what they remember to pass away
unnoticed
writing is not only about Noble and
brave ideas and acts
it is not necessarily about fighting
tyrants or necessarily about standing on
platforms
and making powerful speeches to energize
people
it's about
the ordinary mundane business
of keeping alive what is important
which is about how people imagine
themselves
and how they see and describe the world
they live in
in an important way I think there is a
kind of responsibility in that
writing is resistance to Distortion by
narratives that seek to justify
Injustice
to abstract us from what our mind should
be focusing on
to draw us to other things that might
appear at first more appealing or more
interesting or more immediate
it is resistance in other words to
neglect
and it is important to continue to
uphold those ideas and beliefs that we
think are important and that we value
you get the picture I hope it's about
remembering
a while ago I referred to the way
Recollections of a lost time are taken
to be sentimental and suspect and
nostalgia
I suggested that we hang on to that word
at least in his sense of the distress
aroused by yearning for one's place of
origin
I said earlier that it is a yearning of
those who have lost their homes nor only
too well
towards the end of his Memoir out of
place
Edward said I quote
to this day I feel
that I am sorry
since I'm quoting but I get it exactly
right to this day I still feel that I'm
away from home
I would like to dwell on that for a
moment on what constitutes the ongoing
memory of what has been lost and how
some writers have coped with that
Saeed has written in a variety of ways
about that experience
Somali writer
has only ever written about Somalia
in his 11 novels even though
he has not lived in Somalia for any
length of time since 1970.
I'm concentrating mainly on writers from
shall we say the global South but
because one can think of others as well
Joyce for example
the book of another example
but anyway let's stay with our
community
in His Brilliant early poems Kamal
brathwaite
has the figure of the itinerant
Caribbean man
whom he describes thus in the poem
folkways
never seen a man travel more seen more
lands
then this poor
landless harmless Spade
process that is a question ever seen
anyone like him
he poses that as a question in a way and
in a way it was true to his own life
which is spent largely away from his
home Island Barbados
but he always wrote about the Caribbean
and he returned there in his last days
to live and die at cow Pastor Christ
Church
Barbados the places he described I quote
my maroon town
resistance Palenque
Palenque is the ancient Maya City in
southern Mexico
and its invocation with reference
we're getting both this is typical of
brass wage you know the slash you know
it's this is that so sometimes cow
Pastor sometimes this cow pasture
but the invocation of the reference to
Palenque
this reference to cow Pastor cow pasture
is part of brassway's lifelong idea of a
new World Vision
for the Caribbean a vision whose Force
derived from an Embrace and imaginative
transformation of the Caribbean the
tragic history of the Caribbean slavery
then Plantation
Derek Walcott in school of Lights
has his shabeen after the famous lines
celebrating Caribbean diversity I quote
either I'm nobody
or I'm a nation
before later on enabling that diversity
by casting the Caribbean man as a
homeric hero in search of his place in
the world
the Guyanese novelist Wilson Harris
set all of his 22 novels
in Guyana
even though he lived most of his adult
life in Colchester just outside London
and of course Jean Reese who in her 60s
returned to the Dominica of her
childhood to write white sagasa C
so what is it about place that has this
incredible grip
on the writer's imagination
what is it that makes it so difficult to
give up the force of its memory
isn't one place as good and as good as
another in the end
the causes of the impulse to this to to
disperse to leave home
often have similar sources
and Injustice Terror
discussed or need
and while refugee
appears to be a word with a firm and
clear idea with reference
it includes the terrified rohingya child
and the young African man recklessly
risking everything for a life in Europe
it includes the religious persecuted and
the victims of war and Imperial
aggression
I think that would that what makes it
impossible to give up this memory of
place
is an unredeemed
Injustice
and unappeased longing
where to abandon an obligation to place
and people seems like treachery
however ineffectual and self-tomancing
such memorializing might seem to a
practical-minded person
the impulse to do so
is unavoidable because to do otherwise
to forget
would seem like self-indulgent neglect
thank you very much
thank you